I was not surprised that what went out
and that the show was canceled roseann
bars ex-husband Tom Arnold's claims he
saw her Twitter scandal coming in an
interview with Anderson Cooper 360
Arnold a former writer on the original
roseanne weighed in on bars racist tweet
about Barack Obama's former White House
advisor Valerie Jarrett a tweet that led
to the revivals cancellation I had a
feeling this was gonna happen too when I
first heard it was coming back that
there was a reboot
Arnold explained that he sensed trouble
ahead based on bars historically
controversial Twitter feed I just knew
that this would not end well the 59 year
olds also recalled how he felt prior to
the network canceling the sitcom
I always surprised that they didn't do
anything about it in fact I tweeted a
lot because you know I figure so it
would take your phone away or or or
monitor that because that's a it's a
dangerous you know when you have that
much money on a show the comedian also
spoke with The Hollywood Reporter and
implied to that bar wanted her series to
be canceled quote I am going to tell you
the truth she wanted it to happen if you
saw how her tweets escalated this
weekend bar has continued to tweet since
her show's cancellation apologizing for
her racist remark
you
[Applause]
[Music]